hey guys it's justine and today we're
gonna be going into the metaverse like
what is a metaverse there's not just
gonna be one metaverse there's gonna be
many many metaverses so why i thought
this would be a fun video to kind of
integrate the metaverse into is because
i partnered with prime video to talk
about the upload so season two of the
upload is out now and i actually got a
chance to chat with robbie amell during
season one of the upload now before we
get into all of that the whole concept
of upload and this show is fascinating
because they kind of are giving you sort
of this decision of do you want to
upload your consciousness when you die
now when you do pass on you're able to
take basically all of your memories
everything that you've ever lived and
experienced and you can continue to live
on in this digital world before this
gets interesting is people from your
past or i guess your current life that
are still actually alive are able to
come into this digital world to see you
and interact there's even
um like a
spoiler alert there's a love suit
yeah um that's a thing so it's kind of
fascinating the way that this show kind
of explored this whole other possible
world of what would it be like if we
could take all of our thoughts all of
our memories basically what makes us a
person and upload it to the cloud i
loved season one and now that season two
is out you guys can watch that on prime
video put a link in the description if
you guys want to check it out and not
only that i am so excited because robbie
amell actually made us a little video
that i'm going to show you right here
hey justine i'm so pumped to be back
with you for season two of upload
i mean a lot has happened
since season one you can now increase
the size of your biceps not that i would
ever do that of course i'm all natural
but it is an option
if someone were to want to do it there's
also some negatives uh privacy it's
becoming a big problem here at lakeview
there's a thing called mind frisk where
they can read your thoughts just be
careful uh and also my buddy luke thinks
that they may be spying on his dreams
he's a little nuts so take that with a
grain of salt anyway i hope you have a
blast
and just be careful okay there's a lot
of great but there's also a little bit
of scary now if you haven't checked out
season one of upload make sure you check
out the video justine and i did on her
channel last year have fun justine and i
will see you in lakeview
hopefully not too soon
but one day thank you robbie we cannot
wait to see you in season two and if you
guys haven't watched season one first i
highly recommend watch season one and
then binge your way all the way through
season two it's just such an interesting
show from like the perspective of giving
you this choice of like would you want
to continue to live on in a digital
world after your real life body is no is
no more it's really crazy to think about
but thankfully i don't have to make that
decision right now because i have a
little headset right here that we're
going to put on and uh we're going to go
into we're going to go into the the
metaverse averse of
digital
beings and i don't even know what's
going to happen because i haven't really
explored this whole world and i thought
this would be a really fun video to kind
of have this be sort of like my first
time in the metaverse like what is it
like out there what are the differences
between this kind of metaverse and the
actual
metaverse of lakeview which is the place
that your consciousness is uploaded in
season one and season two of the upload
so uh yeah i guess let's
um let's hop into it i told my sister to
meet me there but she doesn't know what
she's doing either so we kind of just
gonna have to try to figure this out
okay we're going in oh my gosh all right
controllers aren't connected well where
where are my controllers oh no hey jenna
hey
hey okay so i just ordered some food in
the real verse i can't see it any in
front of me i guess do we do we meet up
now let me see how we do this okay so in
pop it in yeah the problem is this is so
heavy on my head everything feels so
heavy oh yeah is this the metaverse
i'm preparing for visitors here we go
okay so what if i click hang out what
happens here okay the sink put your
hands in and hold hands to party up and
explore horizon together okay i'm in oh
my god there's somebody outside you're
gonna have another play anybody here
hello
well i'm gonna follow this dude around
oh anybody hello okay you're in a party
chat can they hear you i don't know man
let me see i want to talk to this new
friend that i've just made i'm gonna
look around for you harassing this
person hey no don't go anywhere
hey come here can't find you dude he
just said he wanted to have a friend and
i'm freaking here and now he's not
um hi
what's up are you up on the top of the
stairs
where are you i don't know
are we in a different metaverse i'm in
the plaza i don't know if i can talk is
this working hello um i also found
something i just took a picture what is
happening this is so silly i'm trying to
make a friend
i don't know what you're trying to tell
me
this kid sounds like he's five can you
hear the app can you guys hello
uh yeah i can hear you now what's up so
exciting well i was in a party chat with
my sister but now i can't find her she's
disappeared
this kid's talking about this girl
victoria how he likes her
me too
i'll be right back i'm gonna see if i
can bring her here this kid is talking
about liking this girl in school like i
thought that this was gonna be like a
super simple
thing that's funny that you thought that
my face is itchy how do you itch your
face in the verse
you don't it's so itchy okay i'm gonna
look at my wrist
i have a notification here
go dude there's no one here
it's me and one other dude there's some
kids throwing paper airplanes yeah i
think we're in two different metaverses
i don't think our verses are sinking
right now
shoot my name justine my name is
ijustine on here okay worlds oh wait
wait wait wait okay all right i love you
hey
invite the world
well some people are saying that they
love each other in here there's love in
the meadowverse okay i'm teleporting
somewhere i was gonna say and i thought
hanging out with people in real life was
exhausting i'm so exhausted oh you see
me turn around i can't turn i can't get
out of this freaking notification i'm
stuck
like get out of it hey oh my god your
outfit's cute
okay you're in my notification hello hi
have a second
i'm just wait move you're in my set
okay
how do you have your settings how did
you do that where is everybody oh you
see me so now that we're here easier way
to turn okay yeah teleport
um slide
you shot me i shot you you hit me with
your finger it went poo poo oh oh you
know what we can do hold on here
oh i feel uncomfortable the other half
of your body let's go let's see what's
over here do you want to come over here
come on over here
are you standing in real life no i'm
sitting i'm sitting i'm gonna jump off
ready
oh god oh no wait i'm floating oh we're
back at the beginning so is this what we
do here come follow me up here grab to
start
oh that's my microphone
i can't grab it because
oops that's my desk
this is a problem okay follow me again
dude i'm trying i'm honestly gonna throw
up this is i don't i don't do well
in vr i mean i'm getting very ill
because i don't get i get motion
sickness oh my gosh i'm sorry so stop
you thought
yeah i don't know if i can be in here
much longer watch me
if you watch it yeah i did it let me do
it too
oh that's bad three hey look over here
oh it hit me did you feel it watch
it feel it
what if i can catch it i'm gonna try it
ready
i can't you got it
oh it went away too fast okay oh shoot i
caught it i'm so talented
oh my god you're so talented so i want
the reason that i wanted to test this
out was to see what the metaverse was
all about this kind of ties into season
two of the upload there sort of
metaverse is you're basically uploading
your consciousness so like there's no
headset because like you're dead
so like after you die this is where you
go this experience is a very subpar
experience compared to what lake view is
like in the actual show
but of course you're also dead so well
yeah if you want to wear a headset
what's at the top of the treehouse i see
you oh god i'm going to fall take me in
i don't think i can i've fallen can i
jump up here take my hand
okay all right well let's skip it let's
go over here let's go to the space
station should we go in this building
oh i really did dude it took me up here
it's it's a little teleportation i feel
nauseous
who's this dude look at this dude with
the hat on oh
i just invited you hey what's up what's
over here is there like what's the space
station we can do this hey dude hello
we visit this world i think i visited a
world where are we going do you guys
come with me the space station oh this
is
definitely making me vomit are you in
these like green tube things yeah i'm in
a green tube thing
i just really don't know about what we
do here
jenna i guess thanks for hanging out the
in the metaverse world
i've lost you in space yeah
but this was really fun i think we
should i know again after we kind of
figure out how to do this this was fun
maybe we could have like a metaverse
meetup we should do that that sounds
definitely should okay well my
wrist has told me that it's 5 20 p.m and
i've ordered dinner in the real world so
i'm gonna go check that out
oh okay okay
thanks for hanging out
bye
i think bye-bye oh my god i'm
how did i end up over here i'm i'm
sideways
like i'm completely sideways all right
well that's
something we did
um
i think that i might prefer to hang out
in lakeview because this experience was
less than stellar and lakeview looks
incredible they have delicious snacks
they have a beautiful buffet of
breakfast foods and it just it seems
like a much more premium experience than
what i just experienced
thank you again to prime video for
sponsoring this video again check out
the link in the description if you guys
want to get more information about the
upload season two and like i said make
sure you binge season one so you'll be
prepped for season two
with that my friends i will see you
in some verse i don't know which one
it's gonna be but
i feel like maybe
i don't know
i feel dizzy
i move okay well there we go
look at my beautiful
world that i will i live here now
oh my god i would totally be lounging
over there i'm in the metaverse now baby
do you even know
anything about anything
oh i'm gonna throw up
this is absolutely nauseating
get me out
get
me out of this
oh my god i can't there's freaking i'm
putting my hands in front of my face
like it's gonna do something
freaking quit
oh my god the elephant's coming towards
me shut up shut up
shut up quit
oh my god help
dude i'm pushing it
get me out quick
which one is that quit there you go
get me out